[Music]
I'm pleased to see all of you here and I
hope you enjoy the day to kick us off we
have the deputy managing director of the
lab Christian Borges who's going to give
a few welcoming remarks Christian okay
so today we are not just celebrating 10
years of Microsoft Research New England
we are celebrating so much more first of
all we really celebrates interaction
with all of you whether you are from the
local Microsoft community known as nerd
New England Research & Development
Center all whether you're from the local
academic community with MIT just the
next buildings there it's already MIT up
to Harvard to the other side of the
river
Boston University bu northeastern you
name University of Massachusetts and so
on this out all of you we first wouldn't
have come here and we really wouldn't be
what we are you will see that in a
moment when we set out to start the lab
we wanted to bring so one of the things
we really care about is also to
celebrate diversity or to be equalized
diversity of approaches so when we
started the lab 10 years ago we really
wanted to bring together the more core
mathematical and computer sciences with
social science economics on one hand and
social media on the other and I think we
achieved this beyond our wildest dreams
we started in economics which actually
no permanent researcher so again you
guys really helped out we had three
visiting professors from MIT and Harvard
a couple of postdocs and today we have a
flourishing group of economists
algorithmic game theorists say
excellence call us but they also
contribute ampere to Microsoft you might
not care that much but my boss Eric
who's somewhere in the audience
might care and if he doesn't care his
boss Harry okay here is Eric and he's
tweeting to Harry about it right now
so Harry might care about that in social
sciences in the social media collective
as we caught it we started with just one
researcher Dana Boyd and today we have a
flourish and group of researchers from
anthropologists to communication call us
they have just had three children
they're produced three books I mean two
of them came out and they actually
presented in this room a few months ago
one is about to come out
and the group is where as Jennifer at
some points at the best social media
group in the world and it seems at least
the local people from the Berkman sort
of and MIT a proof of that so it's
actually the envy of everybody who wants
to visit people fight about being as the
magical visitor in this group and the
group also led to something which is
called fate which was founded together
with our sister lab in New York you will
learn more about that we'll have the
panel and finally in the center sort of
between these branches of economics and
social media our our original
mathematics computer science machine
learning is also really flourishing and
we have many interesting scientific
results I will just mention or ml as one
of them which is a methods how to use
machine learning to actually decide what
models to use in machine and how to tune
the parameters so that you don't have to
do that okay
so I believe that there's a
interdisciplinarity between these areas
is really characteristic for this lab
and to some extent for interaction this
all of you and you will see it in the
parents okay before I just
if you brief overview of the semester
month there's one more group of people I
really have to sing thank and that's the
young researchers our interns and
postdocs we had exactly 90 postdocs by
today in the ten years we had and we had
hundreds of interns and many of them
came from the local community and
several of them actually went back into
the local community and are now
professors at the local universities
some of you are here we think of you
really as part of our family and just
with a real functional family you sort
of never get out of it right so you will
always be part of our lap as will be all
the visitors who have visited us again
many of you from the local community
this that let me talk a little bit about
the pennants we will have five panels
will book ended by the last panel on the
future and starting with a panel on the
usefulness of long term thinking in
between there will be three vitally
interdisciplinary parents one about the
future of machine learning one about
fade I just mentioned it fairness and
ethics in AI and one on the social
science and more general sort of
importance of platform something which
is hardly discussed these days